bonjour c'est vincent lacoste pour brut
[Musique]
la sortie des beaux gosses en 2009
c'était mon premier film donc ça a
changé totalement avis tout simplement
parce que bah déjà c'était en fait j'ai
été pris par hasard dans le film j'étais
en train de manger à la cantine au
collège et une dame est arrivée à donner
des papiers à plein de gens dans la dans
la cantine dont moi et j'ai été à ce
casting et j'ai été pris et en fait je
m'attendais pas du tout à faire ça de ma
vie à la base c'est ça a tout changé
pourquoi parce que j'ai rencontré riad
sattouf aussi qui a été et qui est
toujours une personne extrêmement
importante dans ma vie parce que sans
lui j'aurais jamais fait de cinéma et et
voilà que je remercierai toujours pour
ça et puis ça m'a fait découvrir ce
métier que je q/q honnêtement je pensais
pas être fait pour moi tout simplement
parce que je moi mes parents ils sont
dans des milieux tout à fait totalement
autres quoi et donc je connaissais
personne de près ou de loin qui faisait
du cinéma donc j'ai l'impression que
c'est un milieu quand même assez fermé
et quai ou dans lequel il est impossible
d'entrer dont je m'étais même pas
c'était même pas une je m'étais même pas
posé la question un jour 2 ah oui en
fait j'ai hâte acteurs d'ailleurs j'y ai
même pas été au départ j'ai fait et j'ai
j'ai même pas été au casting c'est un
ami à moi qui a été et qui a été rappelé
et moi j'avais perdu le papier est mon
ami a été rappelé et il m'a dit ah bah
tu devrais y aller m'a demandé pourquoi
tu venais pas etc
j'ai dit ah bon mais toi tu as été
rappelés donc c'est possible ce que moi
je me disais ça est un casting géant
jamais joué de prix de ce sont sarah
rien quoi
et du coup j'ai redemandé le passé mon
pote et j étais puis et c'est comme ça
que c'est comme ça que ça commençait
quoi il ya eu 5 casting et à partir du
troisième j'ai commencé à sentir que que
c'était bien parti parce qu'il commence
à me dire tes parents est ce qu'ils ont
un problème avec le fait qu'il ait
branlette dans le film etc
voilà
[Musique]
le début de la célébrité c'est arrivé un
peu petit à petit surtout parce que j'ai
commencé à être explosé après la sortie
des beaux gosses mais c'est vrai que
c'était un peu étonné que j'étais
vraiment extrêmement moche dans le film
j'avais quand même un peu honte et
surtout la sévérité c'était vraiment des
gens qui passent dans la rue et qui me
font est chaud cette [ __ ] c'est hervé
machin donc c'était un peu
c'était sympa mais le temps c'était un
peu bon genre les gens dans des fêtes où
j'allais de lycées m'appeler hervé tout
ça c'est un peu donc du coup on fait ça
lui un espèce d'effet ou ça m'a rendu un
peu ça m'a un peu rendu timide au départ
vis-à-vis des gens alors ça m'a rendu
timide avec les gens de mon âge en fait
où je me disais j'ai l'impression que
kim associé au personnage du film et que
du coup c'était jean rennes prenait pour
un énorme de losers alors qu'avec les
gens plus âgés qu'ils aient du cinéma il
se disait ah [ __ ] c'est le jeune des
beaux gosses
il est marrant la journée à l'hôpital de
garches pour ma préparation d'hippocrate
le fils de thomas beatie ça m'avait
marqué ou en effet on a tourné à
l'hôpital de garches déjà pendant deux
semaines et on a et on a tourné aussi
dans un hôpital désaffecté mais c'est
surtout que ça m'a fait prendre
conscience du monde hospitalier 2 et 2
la dureté de ce métier quand même et
surtout des responsabilités qu'on des
gens extrêmement jeunes des gens de mon
âge par exemple qui se retrouve à devoir
s'occuper de service et à se confronter
à des choses quand même extrêmement dur
alors qu'eux ils sont en train de finir
leurs études quoi j'ai rencontré des
gens quand même qui qui qui vive pour
pour pour aider les gens les soigner
c'est cc 1
ce que c'est un métier qui a quand même
incroyable quoi